demi lovato went to houston following
the aftermath of Hurricane Harvey she's
opening up to ET about the emotional
experience it was emotional being there
but I also had Kevin Hart and Chris Paul
there and Kevin Hart is so funny he was
the commute it relieved but it was I had
fun it was great working with children
and what exactly were you doing we were
putting together food backpacks I went
to distribute the supplies that was
needed for the victims of the hurricane
I know you've been very vocal about daca
about it being eliminated
tell me about that I think that what's
happening with daca is very important
that people raise the awareness that
it's wrong you know people deserve to be
in the United States especially if they
let their go Hawaiian et spoke with Demi
at the summer spectacular benefiting the
Brent Shapiro foundation for drug
prevention Demi was honored with the
spirit of sobriety award what are the
keys that you do daily that help you
stay healthy I make sure that I work out
it's really important that I keep my
mental health intact I make sure I see
my therapist twice a week I stay in
touch with my recovery team friends
family everybody that is around me
basically well I know you just
celebrated I think five years of
sobriety
do you ever step back and marvel at how
much good you've done and how amazing
you are as a person today well thank you
I sometimes say I just look back and I'm
just grateful to be alive
you know I am grateful that calf sinners
came into my life I'm able to look at my
what I've done and I do kind of like sit
there and think wow I'm so glad that I
got sober and I'm able to help you up
next for Demi a new album tell me you
love me drops September 29th can you
tease one collaboration lonely featuring
I can't tell you come on boy or girl boy
rapper rapper rapper we're excited
you